Unreal Engine 5's Mesh Paint mode allows you to paint on your static meshes, both vertex colors,
vertex weights, textures, and even allows you to blend in between two different materials
should you want to do that. Let's pop into the editor and take a brief look at how we use this
tool now. So before I access the tool, I am going to add myself here a sphere, and this is just
going to give me something to demonstrate the tool with. It's not needed to use the tool, but is
needed for demonstration. So with that added, there we go. I'm going to come up here to activate
the tool by coming down to our selection mode and then going to Mesh Paint. And looks like right
there I have that selected. So across the top we have our vertex color, our vertex weights, our
texture color, and our texture. So textures is going to require a unique setup. It's a little bit
outside the scope of this demo, but let's demonstrate the vertex color. So to do this, all we need
to do is click on the paint here, and then we can just start to paint. And you can see here I'm
painting right in the vertex color information. I can change this to like red. You can tell this
is vertex color because we can see it putting color in between the vertices and we're getting kind
of these little gradients that you see right there. You can also see it snapping to each of the
individual vertices there. But very, very powerful tool. Another thing that we have the ability to
I'm going to come over here to our texture color. If I click on this add right here, check this out.
If I come over here to paint, now I have the ability to actually paint right here on this. And I can
do things like fill, paint different colors, or I can swap my colors here and do all types of
interesting things. And again, I'm doing this all right inside of the editor. So very, very powerful
tool and worth doing some investigating into seeing how this can affect your workflow as,
again, you're working right inside of the editor and it is a super powerful tool to use.